[Music]
first of all email marketing had a
resurgence over the past few years it
went through a slow time where it
received a bad reputation
probably deservedly but unfortunately
there are a lot of experts out there
proclaiming that email is dead or is
dying when you look at the numbers
you'll find that email is actually
growing in acceptance as more and more
email accounts are being created but
also because of Technology because of
the reliance upon the medium of email
and how people use it what we are seeing
is that email is far from being dead in
fact what we see is that email is a
vital link to people in the retailers
businesses and the information that they
want to receive and so let's look at the
value of email and how people use it and
how businesses are using email now as
one of the highest per profit activities
of all marketing channels the first
thing in the morning most people do is
check their email more than any other
facet of online communication email
seems to be the first thing people do to
check and see what messages were
received they sit down and do business
before they've eaten breakfast sometimes
sometimes before they even get out of
bed they're checking their email to see
what was received and what's important
for the first thing in the morning but
more than that for the majority of
Americans email is a dominant activity
when compared to everything else that
people do online people rely on email as
one of the primary activities for their
online behavior and their needs for
going about the day the Direct Marketing
Association even says that email
marketing has two times the return on
investment
other online and offline marketing
channels it's estimated for every dollar
that is spent in email marketing there
is at least a forty dollar return on
that investment
this makes email one of the most
profitable means of online and offline
marketing one thing that has certainly
helped the resurgence of email as a
vital role in business communications is
the explosion of mobile devices and
smartphones in fact one in two of your
emails are probably opened on a mobile
device or think about the ways that you
use your mobile device staying in touch
finding out what's happening using your
mobile device to do that has increased
the amount of times that people check
their email use their email and have
access to their email and so emails
resurgence is certainly dependent upon
the explosion of smartphones and mobile
access but even more so 77% of consumers
prefer to receive permission based
marketing through their email simply
said the majority of people prefer to
receive sales-based emails than getting
sales messages through their social
channels or other means because email is
a more controllable format they can keep
it they can refer back to it they can
print it off it's much more involved and
it's accessible and so people tend to
prefer that they receive marketing based
emails rather than through social
channels or other means so what are
these new developments and email that
have enabled a completely different
level of marketing to take place and it
caused a great resurgence within email
as a highly profitable marketing
activity well the first one is triggered
communications that means that our data
systems have gotten a lot smarter we've
been able to figure out that there are
certain things that we can automate so
that when someone takes a specific
action
we can automate a message as a response
if someone is in the lead process we can
automate emails that will provide a
constant drip of information that will
lead them through the process or educate
them through the process we can also
automate messages based on specific
behaviors so as soon as someone
accomplishes one thing then the system
sends an email to move them along the
way to the next accomplishment triggered
communications are most seen in receipts
and thank-yous and thank yous for
subscribing so trigger communications
have become a vital part in the workflow
because they are preset automated
messages that you create one time and
then you set them to be sent
automatically which saves you time and
money of paying other people to do this
by hand along with better systems as
better data we can understand more about
who our recipients are we can ask for
more information about them we can go to
a third party and supplement the
information that we have about them we
can look at where they are regionally we
can also look at demographic information
we can also look at their tendency to
open emails and click through emails to
see if they're usually on a mobile or if
they're usually on a desktop or if it's
a combination we can learn much more
about our recipients and speak to them
in ways that they want to listen and so
the better we personalize and understand
our recipients the better messages we
can send them one of the greatest things
that has enabled email is the ability to
track email we can look at all of the
links that we send out in an email
message and we can see who clicks on
those links where they go what they do
and we can come up with a valuation of
the profitability of each campaign that
we do and so before you send out the
next campaign you can always go back and
see what worked and what did not work
what did people respond
- what did they not respond to you can
even send to a small test set of names
to see how they respond to test your
email and then adjust it before you send
to the larger group tracking has become
much more proliferates so that we can
see immediately the success of a
campaign and the factors that led to
that success
segmentation enables us to look at our
list in groups rather than as a big
batch of names we can start to segment
out based on behavior what people have
done what they've seen what they
downloaded what they purchased or you
can find out more about your users
simply by asking them and you can find
out their gender their age their birth
date their zip code and so then you can
start to segment by region depending
upon your business and you can send
different messages to different people
from a business standpoint you can email
people differently who live in northern
colder climates than people who live in
southern warmer climates and you can
market to them differently based on the
type of business you are if that's
relevant to you and see differences in
the way people behave just based on
region and when you segment out what
you're doing is taking groups of like
people and treating them differently
based on who they are and when you do
that you move into personalization it's
very easy now just to take the names and
the data that you have in your list and
personalize each email that you send
with the recipients name maybe with
their birth date
or with any other information that you
have the bigger database that you create
about your users the more you'll have an
ability to personalize their message and
the more it's personalized the more
people will react to that you have a
higher open rate a higher quick rate a
higher transaction rate the more
personal your emails become let's look
at how this all comes together with an
example you see it's a numbers game it
starts with the list
as we talked about the most valuable
most profitable list you'll probably
ever build is the one that you develop
yourself what times you may need to go
out and find a list especially if you're
just starting out or getting into a
different area and so it starts with the
list the number of names that you have
to start with the next step is to get
into the inbox there's a lot of
obstacles here because of the
proliferation of spam Internet service
providers have enacted many ways of
filtering email marketing messages if
your email looks too spammy or kicks off
on the filter it won't make it to the
Inbox
and then again you also have at the user
level sometimes people have spam filters
in addition to what their internet
service provider has and so you've got
to get through those filters to get into
the inbox once your email gets into the
inbox you're competing with all the
other emails that a person has received
that day or at that time and so the next
step is to get the user to open your
email and then to click through and as
you can see you're losing more and more
of those names to get to what you want
people to do and so getting people to
open the email is one thing getting them
to click through the offer to find out
more information is another and then
once they see the information they have
to decide that it's relevant and timely
and a necessity for them right now to
get that conversion that conversion
could be a sale or it could be a lead in
this case we're going to make it a lead
because ultimately that lead has to
result in a sale and so we need so many
leads before we can get so many sales
but here's the final cap on the whole
thing and this goes back to one of the
new developments and that's measurement
measurement that is what is the lifetime
value of customers that were acquired
what is the lifetime value of the
loyalty email that we just sent out to
the specific segment what was the value
of that mailing you can measure every
mailing
that you send to every segment and you
can look at the value to know what was
your return on investment for developing
this email or this email campaign and
see immediately how you can adjust what
needs to be adjust or if you need to
change different aspects throughout this
entire measurement funnel the downside
is there's a lot of steps you've got to
look at a lot of different factors to
determine if you had the right message
to the right people at the right time
sending them to the right page with the
right offer in order to get them to
convert and become a lead or a sale but
ultimately you always need to measure
the danger is a lot of people tend to
focus on how many opens did I get or how
many clicks did I get and really what
you're measuring are two steps in the
middle of the funnel rather than
measuring the whole funnel itself
you can't just measure the parts you've
got to measure the entire campaign now
here's an example of a campaign and this
is with a purchase list of high quality
names and we know it's a high quality
list because of the response rate so in
this example the list cost about $5,000
to get 200,000 high-quality names now of
those 200,000 names only 140,000 landed
into an inbox so only about 70% of those
names got past spam filters or were
valid email addresses of that 140,000
only thirty-seven thousand 800 were
opened so we're now down to about 27% of
our names were opened then you'll see a
drastic difference between an open and a
click so the 200,000 names were only
down to about four percent sixteen
hundred and twenty-five names are still
in the frontal and click through to the
landing page of those 16 hundred and
twenty-five that got to the landing page
52 became ally
they converted and became a lead now of
those 5214 became a sail now that's a
conversion rate of 26% which is
fantastic that's great and of those 14
sales we know that there are an average
of four annual sales for every new
customer so if we have 14 new customers
and an average of four sales a year with
an average sale of about eighteen
hundred dollars that comes down to 54
new sales over the lifetime of those
customers that means the campaign
generated eighteen hundred and
forty-seven percent above that $5,000
initial investment for the list there
was a return on an investment of
eighteen hundred percent so as you can
see what it takes to develop an email
campaign is a good list a good offer and
a good conversion rate of getting people
from that lead into the sale and then
looking at your lifetime value helps you
to get a better perspective rather than
just the initial campaign but looking at
the long-term value of a customer that
was acquired through that campaign and
you can see that the return on
investment really makes the case that
email is a highly profitable activity in
terms of the entire marketing mix IBM
created a campaign very quickly with a
budget of $2,000 with that $2,000 they
created a personal trainer email
campaign that went out to IT
professionals for training and education
that $2,000 campaign resulted in
validated leads worth nearly five
million dollars the ROI of that campaign
is well beyond imagination how great
that would have been to have worked on
that campaign and see that return on
investment you see when you've got the
right names
and you bring the right message to the
right people at the right time with the
right offer that is the heart of
marketing and that's what email enables
us to do with a highly measurable and
high return on investment and that's why
email marketing is far from being dead
[Music]
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here